Mele Kalikimaka is the thing to say on a
bright Hawaiian Christmas day thus spake
bring Crosby and a whole load of artists
who covered his song it's not the
Hawaiian has a completely different word
for Christmas
it's just that Kalikimaka is the closest
that Hawaiian can possibly get to the
word Christmas
you see Christmas is a very English
words actually from Old English Christus
mesa the festival or mass of Christ but
the Hawaiian language along with a lot
of Polynesian languages uses only a few
constants and is much more restrictive
phonotactic rules follow tactics are the
way that languages put sounds together
so not sort and wrought of all possible
English words but not isn't you can end
an English word within rain sing
thinking but you can't start one it's
not allowed it sounds non English
English speakers stumble over words from
languages with less restrictive
phonotactic rules so we convert them to
be easier to say it's the bane of anyone
whose surname is when which I've
probably still mispronounced Hawaiian
does the same so how does Merry
Christmas become Mele Kalikimaka well
like this first of all Hawaiian does not
allow more than one consonant together
no cruft or smirk so Christmas becomes
Carissa --mess the tea has vanished
because let's be honest here when was
the last time you said Christmas now
every times a consonant there must be a
vowel after it so Carissa mas app this
is what gives Polynesian languages their
distinct sound and it's why the Hawaiian
state fish is a wonderfully named ho
Mohammed lookin of iguana
Hawaiian has a much smaller alphabet too
it only has eight consonants that last
one by the way is the glottal stop
that's the sound that English speakers
make in the middle of up or button
you'll notice that there's no R in there
in Hawaiian hora and la are
interchangeable actually they're just
the same sound and they're written as LA
so now we have Melly
- listen masa there's no Seether the
closest sound is so switch those over
and there we go Mele Kalikimaka every
language has complicated phonotactic
rules hardly anyone who speaks them
knows what they are but all understand
them intuitively if they grow up with
that language and if you want to see
what happens when someone really plays
about with this check out squirrel by
carla Colston and brian further
it's clapping anchor test and Lea reset
misheard
your belt